curate con la scuola e con uno sono
state oggi nuovissimo gioco dovremo
scappare dallo squalo scuola quale quale
va per iniziare ok vi indichiamo il
tutto mentre scappiamo dallo squalo ma
voi lasciate stupido cantando in cielo
per portarci allora losco lotta può
essere scelta si sono tirati squali
questa volta sono io nasco ok allora
ora bisogna così dire la barca io scelgo
questa che a forma di paparella che gli
orecchini a forma di paperella quindi
spero che mi porterà fortuna come se non
sara cosi gioco speranza prova smi
gravano vero sistema mente in pratica ci
sono due squali gli altri che non solo
squali devono sopravvivere allo scuola
devono cercare di eliminarlo o devono
scappare una volta che finiscono i colpi
invece lo scovano deve eliminare tutte
le persone corso e viene sento a casa un
po di queen among us con l'impostore
allora è questo nella mia barchetta non
ci credo che dovrò provare il bug
arbitale che è un curate con la scuola
del polmone
che paura enorme come si guida questo
perché non so come seguito alla squadra
finisce con guidare uno squalo con me ma
sono io quello che non ho cercato di
imparare come si può avere uno squalo
qualcuno sa che il frutto una barchetta
ma non sono stato io e continuando a
fare le acrobazie ono misto capodoglio
aiuto non so come funziona e
difficilissimo da guidare lo stand altro
c'è il tempo quindi dobbiamo sbrigarci
ok io vado a provare eliminare vita sono
io quello che fai
guarda che tira via di minare le persone
non devi fare le acrobazie la junos col
appena eliminato qualcuno avete visto
aiuto eccolo cosa sono queste cose non
capisco su quali save i due squadre che
sto facendo adesso non sono stato io
sono che è stato mio amico scolora mi
manca una gamba un g credono ma solo mi
ha mangiato una gamba scappare il più
velocemente possibile fermare lo scalo
mi trovi di nuovo aiuto devo andare in
quell isoletta allora non ho letto bene
che cosa sono queste cose rossi sono
mangiato papa vitale l'unico squadra che
non ha mai preso nessun ok ora possiamo
vedere cosa che fa camminando votare da
squalo visto che a me lo sposo mia
eliminata e super d'ufficio non so come
funziona l'italia non mi sento né
acrobazia gli altri giocatori ma che non
va qualcosa un cerchio giallo proceda la
stessa laura se qualcuno da eliminare
ma non so come funziona che bello che
puoi andare a esplorare sotto ma vorrei
che dicesse lo portano in al è
difficilissimo gli mms io non sono stato
mai rivelate nessuno perché l'altra
sponda tanto bravi ok vediamo se
capitolo io come prima rata sarà
vogliono dello sparo no no io che
stamane si è solo uno squalo quindi
possiamo farcela sopravvive allora non
vogliono quella barchetta libro è forse
lei mi piace e tu sei sempre preso la
prima con isla barchetta di legno o no e
di notte quello sarà ancora più pauroso
aiuto diamo subito nella cabina di
pilotaggio
lo show è stato rilasciato quella che
farà io adesso devo capire come si fa a
guidare la barca di legno
ok ok facile ma io non vedo niente dove
saranno del sud
no vabbè vincerà per forza allo stuolo
di si vede niente
cos'è questo cosa da nulla le bolle ok
aiuta forse si possono accendere le luci
ma che non ci sta rotolando lancio non
so perché una barca è già stata
distrutta quindi non ho già attaccato
sede qua c'è qualcuno li poverino vado a
salvarlo con la mia barca ei tool sani
pure qua sto arrivando a chi o 91
speronato però mamma mia
no io sono barca di legno che stava
barca così bella che se muscolari ma che
fai come giusto distrutta venga prende
nome ho mangiato una vera fuori tutti su
santana però o no no no no no questa
musica si pongono che anzi accanto grave
aiuto perché non si è esaltato da qui la
barca non ho fatto in tempo a qualcuno
venga a prendermi in offerta aiuto
scelto stato eliminato
[Applauso]
[Musica]
bravi tutti e sta per iniziare la
prossima partita e spero di diventare io
uno squadra che voglio vedere come una
scuola e nel frattempo esploriamo questa
notte si può sparare come nave un faro
noi siamo in un faro sulla terraferma
cretino noi chiediamo chi è il prossimo
squalo
[Musica]
non ci dobbiamo scappare dallo squalo
nei preparativi diretto con teheran che
dice di seguire le bollicine così posso
trovare le barche invece le bollicine
rosse non sono sempre bordone per
mangiarla sarà molto emozionante
dirò che assistono rilasciando era 40
paura ma quello sono io
questa è una barca pensa come lo sono io
ti ho detto di assica per una roccia mi
spegnere le luci che diamo a prenderlo
ecco la zona barca prese là dove noi
abbiamo alcuna pace qualcuna diamo
mangiano o no la roccia ecco mi sto
avvicinando a qualcuno o che avevano
giocato meglio di giorno è molto meglio
allora sembra che lui in quanto capita
che alcuni a prendere questa perdita
vediamo il desire z capanna ei come si
fa ad uscire dalla fine io prendo la
frattura fatto guadagnato 5 denti la
jesi una barca proviamo a prenderla
vediamo se sei tu questa israelita non
sono io quello ti prendono ripreso
qualcuno non ci fermeremo con tutta la
barca fino qua ci sono un sacco di
persone sono mi sta sparando aiuto ei vi
prego
wow eliminato un sacco di persone
ammesso che mi ricordi
vediamo qua c'è qualcuno l'ha se lo
prendo
ti vedo giu chi è questo sarà vitale
ci vediamo qualcuno si sta nella roccia
ti aspetto qui se qualcun altro come
vediamo dice qualcuno tutto arrivando a
prendervi vi conviene e tappare kitsch
equa e che succede
[Musica]
riesco a prendere guarda già sparato ci
volete che vi prestano nascosto breve vi
prego non sono quello ho eliminato
qualcun altro ha sempre visto giocare
come scuola vincendo dove sei tu ti devo
trovare devo trovare evitare
assolutamente nagel sparato sei colpi
non ci ho preso già beta sono troppo
lontano mi sono nascosto manca da
prendere siamo rimasti in tre trovare
gli altri dove stavano trovò non capendo
il tempo dove fanno gli altri
devo sbrigarmi dove stare se qualcosa va
giù
ok c'è qualcosa laggiù preparati
chiunque
no non te tu però è che vista forse mi
sa che sono rimasto solo io si no ho
finito i colpi mi hai preso
essi sono rimasto l'unico sopravvissuto
si italia no no ha sparato tutto dieci
corpi senso neanche colpirti attacco
però devo dire che per essere la prima
volta che facevo la scuola ho giocato
per tutti uguali
ok una persona quindi ripete siamo nella
stessa barca proviamo allora io quella
blu non mi piaceva tanto quindi ho
scelto la paperella adesso a nella
stessa barca insieme dice ok ok allora
anche la paparella e non fossi faremo
nella stessa barca però no vengo a
trovarti ok fronti vi piace queste zone
dove bene ma qualcuno ha sparato col
campo né no non siamo nella stessa barca
e come individuate in questo film come
guardata arrivando da che sta vivendo la
scuola
dobbiamo stare sopra attenti 76 qui qui
fermo ferma è bello vederlo
ecco mi aspetta basta avere tutto sulla
mia barca bravo ma allora tu guida e io
prendo bravo che ha fatto si sa fare ok
che cos'era stava volando li hanno
sprecato un colpo per la lazio dobbiamo
trovare lo squalo è comodo se uno guida
e l'altra poi facile ma credo che quello
certo lo squalo dove agli utenti dove
dio proprio di fronte a noi
io ho visto ci avviciniamo contro e
speriamo che proviamo sarà un po
difficile beccarlo no non l'ho beccato è
andato sott'acqua andando a distruggere
quella nave sicuramente li vedo molto
male quelli la giovane scomparso grazie
apcom costa musica che abbiamo vicino a
diventare notte così in un attimo è
molto più difficile di notte bianca la
barca a vela che carina eh qui qui dopo
vicino noi dovete mio fianco
cos'è cosa c'è allora non credo ce lo
sta aiutando nessuno scappiamo abbiamo
ce l'abbiamo corvino sistema che spesso
quando aiuto va velocissimo cercando di
scappare più velocemente possibile
l'abbiamo ancora vicino non lo vede più
no dovrebbe essersi allontanato non è
qui a fianco a noi non lo so il pallino
d'oro si sta dicendo che fai si speroni
cos'è la ma qualcuno che ci spara noi
c'è un suono strano che succede
fortunatamente non aprirà
[Musica]
certo sotto giocato sul bianco aiuto k
se qui è più che bene questo campo ecco
le scuole ci stanno venendo a prendere
per fortuna sono salvato ei qui nella
parte ok ma che fanno questi tra 28 la
paperella siamo salvati per un pelo
qui tra l'altro lo scalo scuola lo vede
è scaduto il tempo abbiamo fatto questa
che ci ha voluto recuperare ma vediamo
se capite remo squali
vediamo chi sarà lo scalo non noi
noi proviamo l'ultima volta a mettersi
in salvo ma allora cambiamo bar che mi
aiutato da proprio nella vicina gen
io scelgo questa barchetta in legno dino
viani molto più passato allora come si
guida questa barca di andare dietro
ok arriva lì si staccata mandibola per
un momento se la barca c'è la
percentuale che la scuola ti può
prendere in su oltre 900 team 18 forse
perché la tua non far rumore è più lenta
quindi non sapevo allora conviene
prendere quelle meno come rosa ha già
eliminato qualcuno devo prendere
l'ho visto però è già sprecato un colpo
a caso però credo di averlo visto io
vado insieme alle altre bar e così ci
proteggiamo la somma questa non l'ho
mica ora sono più vicino a te che carina
questa barriera ho visto lo squalo visto
la scuola ho visto lo squalo vicino
l'isola sta barchette bellissime tipo lo
sling di babbo natale hanno eliminato
qualcun altro però l'hanno colpito è
vicino al faro del proprio vicino a me
aiuto non ti vedo sono vicino la buona
questa è una barca fatta a pezzetti
vediamo stesse combattendo a casa di uno
squalo è sotto di te come senza di me no
non c'è nessuno fa eco logic più vicino
o no o no l'ombra qua sotto
o forse la mia ombra se neanche salendo
il sole per fortuna molto meglio detto
già sparato cinque colpi ed ha ecco lo
squalo lo vedo dove li sta arrivando
verso di te paparella ha colpito la
comunità si dai proviamo a colpirlo
tengono molto vicino che paura colpo
dove sei
ok ok si sia ferito i colpi quindi può
venire sulla mia barca così tu puoi si
allontana no non l'ho preso e
difficilissimo da prendere se sono qui
dietro di te se vuoi salire così guidi
tutto perfetto fino a riprendere questo
strano no e non è tutto
[Musica]
no ho guidato un po male
ma eravamo gli ultimi è stato super di
martin sorrell e volete che facciamo
altre parti sono un altro la scuola
stato mi piace se questo video
raggiungere i 7 mila mi piace fare
un'altra pisa non lo so e ora mi
lasciavo 4 casellina weekend i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite prima che arrivi lo squalo
[Musica]